Carl jung says that everything
unconscious is projected into reality.
How do you know if you are perceiving
reality accurately or are just projecting?
Great.
Yeah,
well,
that's partly why I'm a pragmatist.
While there's a bunch of ways,
um,
there's a bunch of ways that you know,
pain tells you
if you make a mistake and you hurt
yourself while then you're stupid.
Theory was wrong,
right?
That's what the pain says.
You're stupid theory was
wrong and that's a pragmatic,
you see,
that's another indication of
pragmatic theory of truth.
You lay out.
Look,
when you look at the world,
you look at the world with
a set of presuppositions.
I outlined that in chapter 10 in in rules,
in 12 rules for life called
be precise in your speech.
It indicates that when
you look at the world,
you look at it through a value structure.
You can't help that because you're always
aiming at something in the world and
you're always aiming at something
you want and you're trying to get it.
And so that means that you look at
the world through a value structure.
Now the question is whether or
not that value structure is valid.
And that's a very complicated question.
Okay,
so how do you know if it's valid?
Number one,
you lay it out and you acted out,
you,
you implement it perceptually
and then you act it out.
And if you get what you wanted,
what the theory predicted,
that's another way of thinking about it,
but wanted is a better
way of thinking about it.
Then the fact that that behavioral routine
and perceptual structure produced the
intended result validates it as
a tool for obtaining that result.
And that's a form of truth.
Now,
it might be the only form of truth,
although I'm not convinced
of that completely.
But it might be,
it's a very complicated question.
Now,
how do you know if you're
stupid theory is wrong?
Okay?
A,
it fails and you're hurt.
Pain tells you,
you pragmatically,
your theory was wrong.
So that's why you should pay attention
to your own pain because your suffering
is indication that you
still have things to learn.
And maybe the suffering of
other people is also that,
um,
maybe something unexpected
or unpredictable happens
when you're laying out your
plan and then the
anomalous manifest itself,
the unexpected or chaos
and then you get anxious.
Well,
anxiety is an indication that your plan,
your Arrow didn't fly too.
It's mark so you aimed wrong and
that might mean a small error,
you know,
maybe a tiny adjustment of your bowl or
it might mean you just don't know what
the hell you're doing at
all and everything is lost.
And so anxiety tells you if
your theory is wrong and then,
and then other people tell you that.
And that's why you want to surround
yourself with other people because you
distribute your cognitive resources.
Ew,
ew.
You distribute your problems to the
cognitive resources of the social group.
That's what we do when we price things,
right?
Everyone votes on the price of something
because it's so difficult because the
price of something has to be established
in relationship to the price of
everything else.
And that's always in flux and so it's
computationally impossible problem.
And so we outsource it to the market,
which is the free cognitive
decision of millions of people.
And that's how we determined price.
And so one of the things you do to make
sure that you're not any stupider than
you have to be blind,
ignorant,
biased,
and all of that is you surround yourself
with other people and you try to treat
them well enough so that
they can tolerate you.
And then every time that you do something
stupid because one of your theories
is,
is vague or incomplete or wrong or biased,
or you're willfully blind,
then they slap you on
the side of the head.
They ignore you because you're boring.
They don't laugh at your
jokes because they're stupid.
They,
they,
they are irritated at your
auctions because you're not
taking your own longterm
interests or the interests
of other people into account.
And so you have pain,
you have anxiety,
you have the reward of
success that that's,
that's a positive indicator
that your theory is okay.
And then you have the
reactions of everyone else.
And if you're clued in,
you pay attention to all of those
things and you try to update your,
your order,
which is your perceptions.
You try to update your order constantly
as a consequence of being humble in the
face of your errors,
which is why humility is the precondition
of her learning and why it's one of
the highest moral virtues.
So.